the fourth and final baby three boys and
now we're having our first girl she's
gonna be soon and the Pain's gonna be
gone okay
hi I'm Hannah I'm the world's Case Mom
and I am 39 weeks pregnant very much
over it very much ready for this to be
done so imagine my surprise nine short
months ago I find out that I'm pregnant
again but it was such a welcome exciting
surprise I'm always so excited to
welcome one more and then imagine my
absolute shock when we find out we're
having a girl I thought we only made
boys honestly didn't quite sink in until
she was born that we were gonna have a
daughter you might have seen that with
my current youngest Henry I ended up
filming his birth I never documented any
part of birth before that and it was so
amazing to film it and get to
re-experience it so I've decided I'm
gonna do it again because birth is so
different every time I am going to take
you along on this journey of the fourth
and final baby give me some eviction
Vibes let's get her out I should have
known that maybe I was having a girl
because this pregnancy was so different
from my other ones it was
so much harder I was really really sick
violently ill for about 17 weeks I had
way more pain more fatigue more
heartburn nausea at the end of pregnancy
just all those side effects of pregnancy
that you read about I was experiencing
all of them I would love for her to come
out soon because I'm not sleeping at
night at all I'm over it I'm not one of
those people who likes being pregnant at
all someone said can you say one good
thing about pregnancy and I was like
no
39 weeks
about done I'm so
it Dawns on me I literally haven't
bought anything for this baby and I'm
totally unprepared so I was feeling
really panicked about a couple key items
that I hadn't bought yet but Matt had a
little surprise for me I do this every
time I don't buy a stroller then the
baby's here then I panic I get backed
into a corner I buy whatever strollers
at the store and I don't like it it's
not the stroller I wanted so I was
venting to Matt and he said
do you want your surprise and I said yes
so he's outside getting something and
I'm very excited to see what it is
oh my God
what
what oh my gosh okay where did this come
from your friend sent me money with
Zella so I was able to get this cooling
stroller oh my gosh that's so sweet
it's the one I wanted money was in my
account so fast I was able to get it
right away oh my gosh okay let's take it
for a test run let's get the kids
looking good who's gonna sit behind you
so having a girl opened up just a whole
world full of names as well and we were
so overwhelmed choosing a baby name but
I found out about something super cool
that's kind of new to me baby name
consultations so I reached out to this
really sweet woman named Morgan and we
booked a baby name consultation and did
it over video chat hi Morgan hi Hannah
thank you so much for doing this I can't
tell you how many names I've picked and
we've decided on and then a week later
I'm like I hate it we're done we're not
using this we're starting all over what
is your process for for whittling down
the names for people I've got big
databases full of like names just from
different Vibes different Generations a
lot of parents want different sounds or
letters so I've got just Google Sheets
on Google Sheets that have lots of
different um categories of names what
did you come up with yeah well I was
looking at your boys names Jackson and
Wyatt and Henry and I feel like birthday
then it's classic but maybe a little bit
Western and a little bit vintage and
then I really liked leaning into that
vintage Vibe so if you had to pick one
name that's like your number one
recommendation for this baby what would
that name be based on the names that you
were giving me I really liked the idea
of Birdie and even if you didn't use
birdie directly
um names like ran you can get anything
Brody from or Beatrice or even like
Roberta I just got big birdie vibes from
you that's so funny because we
definitely have noticed that we like the
E sounding ending of her names like
birdie it's so cute and it just feels
really playful but I love that n Sound
thank you so much for helping me
organize my thoughts and I feel like
even if we don't use one of the names
that you suggested it's another really
good starting point for us to kind of
associate even more names that we might
not have thought of well thanks Morgan
thank you so much Tiana and I will I'll
let you know what we end up with so with
Henry I ended up being induced because
he was born really close to Christmas
and we just wanted a little more control
over this situation and I wasn't gonna
do that this time around but she wasn't
coming out and so we decided to go with
inducing again this time because we
needed a really Ironclad plan for child
care if I were to go into labor in the
middle of the night we have three kids
who someone has to stay home with and we
live really far from my family so with
that date in mind I really had high
hopes to do a lot of family stuff do a
lot of outings and of course nothing
ever goes to plan and we all got very
sick with a really bad cold so the last
week was spent trying to get everybody
healthy trying to find moments to do fun
stuff together while we can inside and
just make sure that no one has a cold
when this baby comes how many are there
one two three four
five
almost
four days until my induction
and I woke up this morning
50 times worse I feel like
garbage
[ __ ] I'm trying so hard not to throw up
I wanted to spend these last few days
like enjoying time with the kids
and here I am stuck in bed oh my God I
look like poop
I really wanted to dedicate a lot of
time to Henry because
I knew that this was going to be a rude
awakening for him he is so much the baby
of the family I knew it would be a big
adjustment for him
um because we're so close so I dedicated
a lot of time to Henry a lot of cuddles
to Henry because he knew a baby was
coming but I don't think he really knew
what it meant TMI if I don't like
regularly pee every time I cough I pee
my pants I've had to change my pants
three times today because she's so low
and she's putting so much pressure on my
bladder so I had my final doctor's
appointment before my induction date
it's two days away
um I needed a cervical check and I'm
three centimeters dilated I was having
some contractions not painful ones he
did what's called a like stripping your
membranes
um which is kind of like loosening the
amniotic sac from inside the uterus it's
supposed to help with like a smoother
labor it wasn't like unbearable or
anything but it was uncomfortable
um and that was it so now we wait but I
can't stop pee
so
I feel like it's um it's near this is
the last
full day of the baby bump okay I'm
headed to the hospital for my
pre-screening that they do before
induction they're gonna take urine
sample probably blood they're going to
cover test me and then
it's like all done and set so that I can
come in tomorrow and not have to deal
with it okay so I just finished at the
hospital I'm gonna go get myself a
little treat because this is my last day
as a pregnant woman oh my God it's all
happening this is crazy so my mom is
here I'm all set to go at
5 a.m tomorrow hi guys hello
are you excited
to have a baby sister tomorrow yeah
who's gonna hold her first me me
I'm gonna miss you guys tomorrow
I'll be at the hospital I know
do you want to say anything to your
sister before she's born hi we're doing
a bedtime book for honey
last night as the youngest when I come
home
I'm coming home with your sister
okay good night guys good night so our
induction appointment was 5 a.m but that
did Grant me the luxury of getting ready
for birth I got to do my hair and makeup
it felt very reminiscent of having Henry
it was like total flashbacks to putting
on my makeup pitch black outside in the
bathroom heading out in the darkness to
go to the hospital so I get to the
hospital I get admitted I go to my labor
and delivery room and they did a
cervical check on me which is basically
they shoved their whole like arm up
there to reach her cervix and see how
open it is and to give birth your cervix
goes from completely close to 10
centimeters dilated which is how open it
is to fit the baby out so every time
I've gone to the hospital I've been at
about a three or a four centimeters
dilated it's kind of that pre-labor
where your body is starting to get
warmed up I was six centimeters dilated
so I had been in medium labor I'd say
where things were really moving quickly
I just hadn't noticed I'm six
centimeters dilated so
they were like do you want you might
want to get your epidural now if you
want it because it's going to go really
fast probably
once they hook me up to the pitocin this
one's very different than than me yeah
like Henry it just wasn't budging
this one's like lightning speed
knock on wood
um yeah I hate this is my least favorite
part I hate IVs
and I'm hungry anesthesia has a whole
Hospital full of
potent to so they're not always at your
beck and call so the timing is really
important for getting your epidural and
I opted to get it before they hooked me
up to the pitocin so that if things got
crazy I'd at least have that epidural
I'm hooked up to fluids
and they're going to come in as soon as
I've had enough fluids they're going to
come in and give me my epidural and then
hook up the pitocin I can feel myself
having a contraction though
oh
they're getting a little more frequent
I'm like maybe I just slipper normally
so they gave me a bit of time just to
see what would happen and you know maybe
the labor would kick start on its own
but eventually I got hooked up to
pitocin which causes synthetic
contractions I guess and usually helps
move things along
just a waiting game nice and comfy
though because I have my epidural so
epidural is on a constant drip it's kind
of just the same as an IV but it's in
your spine which is a little scary but
you know when you're in that level of
pain it's it's in my opinion very much
worth it I'm having contractions but my
water needs to break in the meantime
while we were waiting for my doctor uh
we decided to try some positions to see
if my water would break they ended up
sitting me upright
um in the hospital bed it's not working
nothing's really happening so Matt and
my mom decide to go get coffee and in
the meantime we are planning to put me
back on my back and try something called
a peanut ball it's a big ball shaped
like a peanut you put it between your
legs they get the paintball in and what
do I feel I feel basically a rubber band
snap inside of me that's how I would
describe your water breaking oh my God
okay now like fluid it's come here
my epidural was gravity based so when
they put the epidural in your spine it
goes with the gravity of your body the
epidural wasn't up here anymore because
I had been sitting up I'm gonna start
breathing now start breathing now there
you go
like a wave okay it's gonna come and go
the contractions just ramp up from zero
to a hundred oh my God
oh my God they're like oh snap your mom
and Matt have to get back now it's so
bad
oh my God
okay
and so they called anesthesia to try to
get them to come up and give me what's
called a bolus which is basically just a
boost of medication to try to make it a
little more pain-free but anesthesia was
in an operating room I just started
getting flashbacks to Henry's birth of
the realization that I was gonna feel it
again she's gonna be soon and the Pain's
gonna be gone okay I promise
oh my God
when they went to look to see if my
water was broken they saw a head
and so she was ready she was like ready
to fly out and be born
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh I know
beautiful 150. she's gorgeous
people I'm gonna talk her into you okay
honey oh my God that was so fast
one push
baby girl oh Dad proud dad
oh my gosh I love you
I love you I immediately knew that I was
gonna need stitches usually if you're
doing like pushes every contraction then
your body stretches with each
contraction and with each push but with
her she just kind of flew out of me but
I was just so happy I didn't care I was
like do whatever you have to do I'm so
excited and happy to meet this little
girl
[Music]
is changing his first girl diaper
she just keeps peeing and pooping
no matter how fast you wipe
Deuce poop
so my mom
's so excited for us to get home we
walked through the door with little
Lenny Jaheen in her car seat and the
boys just blocked to her
[Music]
now I knew Henry wouldn't take it great
that he just he had a whole meltdown in
that moment it dawned on him like this
is here to stay
this
Jackson and Wyatt are seasoned Pros they
are seasoned big brothers and so they
were just so ready to hold her and I
think that helped Henry get more excited
too and kind of snap out of the shock
and sadness of of seeing this little
baby and so he got really excited to
hold her as well we were still
recovering from this cold couple kids
had to wear masks because I just didn't
want her to come home and immediately
get sick so it wasn't that close contact
welcome that I had really hoped for but
we worked with what we had the boys got
to all hold her
okay I'll be gentle Henry what should we
do she's crying
what he's crying about she's hungry
Matt is obsessed with her oh my gosh
she's just his world we fight over being
able to hold her it's been so so surreal
and so special and she's just magical
perfect
magical
girl in the family a new baby girl
cheers
that's good it's just so exciting to
welcome Miss Lenny Jean our baby girl
into our family it's a Wild final
chapter of Parenthood I'm just so
excited to finally introduce you to her
but I can't hear her crying she's really
pissed and hungry so I better go so
that's all for now I'm Hannah and if you
have a birth story to share message me
on Instagram if you have any questions
about birth message me on Instagram too
if you please excuse me we're gonna go
take our very first family walk and move
her into the
snazzy new stroller till next time
[Music]
[Music]